- But before all that, we need to talk
to a guy we are obsessed with.
I personally am.
I love him. I've known him for years.
I love doing his show,
especially the day drinking part.
He's the host of Late Night on NBC
and his new kids book is called
"I'm Not Scared, YOU'RE Scared!"
and it's out now.
I love that title.
He is on the line right now.
What's up Seth?
(audience cheers, lively music plays)
- Kelly!
- Hello! So first I'm very
excited to talk about this,
but first happy St. Patrick's Day.
So what's like your best New
York St. Patty's Day memory?
- Well, my best St. Patty's
day memories are Chicago based.
That's where I went to
college and we used to go
to downtown Chicago and drink green beer
in plastic solo cups.
And green beer is great
(Kelly laughs)
because it basically is telling you
how your night's gonna end
(Kelly and audience laugh)
because the green beer
doesn't end up in the belly
the green beer sort of it's
a gift back to the world.
(audience laughs)
- It makes for an encore.
It has an encore.
It comes back. (chuckles)
- Yeah, so basically when you drink it,
it says, "I'll see you soon."
(Kelly and audience laugh)
- (laughing) I don't know
if I've ever had green beer.
It doesn't sound enticing.
So your new book is called "I'm
Not Scared, YOU'RE Scared!"
Can you tell us about it?
And I love the title by the way. (laughs)
- Thank you.
I was gonna write one based
on our day drinking called
"I'm Not Drunk, You're Drunk"
(Kelly and audience laugh)
but the publisher said
that wasn't good for kids.
- It would also be a great book. (laughs)
- I wanted to write a book.
I'm so fascinated, having kids,
with how they approach
their own fears and anxiety.
So I wanted to write a story
that had a beginning, middle, and end
and some excitement and
a bit of an adventure
but also was maybe the kind of book
where parents and kids could talk
about things that their kids are afraid of
and how sometimes kids
are afraid for no reason,
and sometimes they're smart to be afraid.
And as a parent, you appreciate
when they don't wanna go
to the tallest part of the jungle gym
in a playground when
they're not old enough.
So it's hopefully a nice
discussion about fear and anxiety.
That also is fun for
parents to read to kids.
- Yeah. I mean, honestly,
as a parent, I mean,
I couldn't think of a better book.
I read every night to my kids,
and there's been so much fear
and anxiety just around COVID
about everything that's been
happening the last two years.
And then there's just so much
fear and anxiety for everyone
that do you ever, your kids are young
but do you ever, does any
of these topics ever come up
like how to deal with that?
- You know, they're a little bit young,
but certainly the fact that
they've been wearing masks
for a couple of years,
it's impossible not to talk to them
about what we're going through
and how sort of a collective sacrifice
is necessary for the
health of and wellbeing of
of those who are, you know,
more compromised during a
difficult time like this.
So you try to have those conversations
in a way they understand
while appreciating
they're probably a couple
years away from fully
being able to grasp everything
that's going on in the world.
And that isn't necessarily a bad thing.
I wanna let them be
kids as much as possible
and they can deal with adult
life when that rolls around.
- Absolutely, it's funny though.
My kids, like, pre-COVID...
I'm the parent,
I've never been the parent that's like
"oh my God, don't touch
her," or "don't lick that,"
you know, I'm like the
parent to my kid that's like
"oh, it's free probiotics, it's fine.
It dropped on the ground, like
just, you're gonna be fine."
So I went from that person,
now my kids are like masked up
and we're going out and
I'm like, "don't touch it."
And they're like "you
said, free probiotics."
(audience laughs)
Like they literally
threw "free probiotic."
My daughter threw it back in my face.
And it was an interesting
conversation how to explain that.
But I love this,
and you wrote that you
are hoping your children,
I love this, hoping your
children like this book
because none of them can stay up
late enough to watch your show. (laughs)
(audience laughs)
- Right.
- So that's amazing.
So they have no idea who you are really.
And it's like, it's amazing,
cause you have such an
impact on pop culture
and they have no idea.
And it's awesome that this
will be their introduction.
Do they like the book?
- They do like the book.
I told them the story first
before I put it down on
paper and got their approval.
Their favorite part of the book
by far is the dedication page
because I dedicated it to them.
And so they show that to people
as if it means they wrote the book.
(Kelly and audience laugh)
- Well, thank you so much, Seth.
I love you so much.
(audience applauds)
I love the book!
I will be reading this
with my kids tonight.
Everybody pick up his new book,
"I'm Not Scared, YOU'RE
Scared!" it's out right now.